hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm still not a brony yet Bing so
let's get back into it I want to see the
ending of this cuz it could be something
fantabulous spectacular ball amazing
ball amazeballs there could be a maize
ball at bro I feel like that's actually
a phrase acronym LTF stands for love
tolerance friendship which sums up both
the goals and methods of the
Foundation's actions well isn't that
nice
I'm at the computer person so if I can
just get um turn off the power
I think that'll allow me to get inside
and then he'll send me to turn the power
back on for the secondary power and then
he should open a door and I should be
able to get out I should be able to get
out but then again I kind of want to see
six eight two and what he's all about
but beggars can't be choosers I'll just
have to try Olo okay so let me go but
actually let me see what's this way
first and then I'll see hello I don't
remember this what is this
wait I've never seen this before what is
this SCP seven for the
wait a minute I'm glad I came this way
what is this
well something happened what is this but
on the ring it lowered my run speed
I can't run what does it do
I don't know somebody explain what that
does and no nothing there's absolutely
nothing in here huh I guess these must
be the new SCP so they added in but
doesn't seem to be much a CP 102 5
there's not even a piece of paper that
explains it I'm gonna have to look it up
later cuz I do not know off the top of
my head just exploring a bit more before
I go back the other way
hello hi you're one of those protection
doodads aren't you you're gonna shoot me
if I go in there angel angel you would
oh hello uh-huh what I'm not a good
picture that's a bad picture okay this
is radical Larry or um Rainbow Dash I
think that's the name of it sentient and
violent why I call him radical Larry
radical rainbow yeah it works
all right first Tesla gate I've come
across yeah there's not much let I'm not
this again
hey now you're an all-star game on I'm
not going through there alright let's go
back I don't like going through there
anyway
wait a minute why didn't it do the sound
thingy hi but ghosts
don't eat my butt please don't eat my
butt my butt is not for eating
on a sidenote I'm not wearing any pants
oh I never record with pants on it
allows me the freedom that I need in
order to get my improvisational comedy
going Pat a dad exactly why hey enough
silliness let's get back to business I
need to huh hi hello
oh that's the zippy do that one there
you are hello 8uq Oh God I don't know
dayz warez earlier shot of a [ __ ] are
you okay you're in there don't move you
dick don't move don't move
Elmo Elmo good pony here's a good pony
ok now I got to go back this way
Oh piss oh come on hey going through
here where are you there you are
don't kill me don't kill me kill me I'm
almost done up like ok I stop don't kill
me don't kill me
ah good damn it
ha you stop it
you stop it bro I don't want it ok we're
here now let's go up here and turn off
the power I should have done this in
beginning I don't know why cuz I didn't
know that I'd be running into the
computer guy
that's why save it's dark up here here
we go ok
primary lighting off secondary lighting
one remote door control off there we go
it's dark now I forgot that it got dark
I can't see a damn thing where am i
where am i where am i I don't know where
I am I can't see anything
it's like totes mix Krauts dark bro
where am I rabbi ah light up some man
relax me in the door wait hang on
there's a lamp but I don't know where I
am
how did I get lost not cool bro if I
keep running eventually I'll get
somewhere right whoa oh oh whoa was that
wait no that's all coming and I saw I
can barely see woosh Nikes oh boy where
am I wait hang on there's something else
there's another lamp and oh god I'm
walking right into ah but I just cause
where am I
where the hell am i well LM I why is it
dark
it should not be dark here why is it
what did I just pick up
what is us ha ha ha
love's going on who's that and I saw
something oh wow
where am I where did I get a kick hard
no pass where the hell did I go bruh
can't see anything
where did I go what happened
turn the lights I'm screw this I'm out
here got up oh not cool
what happened they've never gone total
pitch blackness before okay please don't
bug out on the save game I'm almost at
the end here I just want to get out
there hello man maybe I just need to
turn off the remote door control that's
what they need to do I can leave all the
lighting on don't turn off the lighting
don't turn off the lighting that is key
oh come on load Jesus how slow can you
be really you're gonna crawl along at
less than a percent a second really
really is that okay there we go
Jesus okay here we are we're back up
here don't know how all that happened I
just need to turn off the remote door
control I turned off the front
okay I was supposed to turn the lighting
back on that's right I wha what happened
I got like jerk to the side I want to
know where the hell I went that I got
that I actually got a key
oh I must have made my way add hair ah
bill piss Oh mother mother hubbard i
don't lie how'd you get there this bull
you need to stop moving breath okay I
gotta go I gotta let go let's just get
out of here we're almost at the end is
Pinkie Pie down here I don't know
ah way up here you need to stop going
places not cool you stay right there
stay right there stay right there
let's go go go go go go go go go go go
not cool
what the hell must know that I'm a bar
I'm approaching an end Jesus I actually
have to go back one more time before
it'll let me end this well that's new
okay so I should be able to flip through
here yes there we go hello
talk to me listen closely know is
important okay a weight choice yours to
make the right selection or a big
mistake if a long time you choose smooth
foundation so uh want me to go turn them
when we go turn the control on again
that so what you want me to do
you didn't say but I'm assuming that's
what you want me to do okay ah I'm sure
man
bro just got to go through pinkie pie
again come on bring it on super running
huh the hell's going on in this place
this is all the pony stuff is starting
to get to me
not in here right
not in here that would have been bad if
it was in there cuz I was not paying
attention okay come on here we go thank
you bye you down here
big pink [ __ ] you
can't what the long still nothing no
sign of her him her her I think it's her
sounds like you're her come on let's run
run we got places to be
it's gonna keep this on for the moment
I'd hope that radical Larry does not
show up again okay here we go
remote control on
okay so now I can go find the exit I
still don't know where the gate be no
[ __ ] off we're going here go we're going
man run run run leave them in the dust
look at me go Oh No I fell through the
floor
no God fudge oh na na oh please work
don't follow me through the floor why I
thought they'd fix that fall through the
floor unload game problem I thought they
did but they apparently did not they did
not do that oh come on you slow loading
bastard I thought they fixed the slow
loading too but as mod must be running
no it can't be running on an older
version because it had those new a/c
Peas I never seen unless those were
there before I have no idea all pass
come on it's gonna follow me through the
floor heads go
he did not oh I did not
oh I'm so happy did I already go in here
I think I did oh thank you oh thank you
thank you so much okay so I'm gonna end
it here oh oh I thought it did but it
did not so we're gonna get to gate B and
see the ending in the next episode so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos if I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
this video contains scenes of extreme
my name is
little
No
yeah so